Okay so
I get white against Duda
pretty um
pretty tough opponent right there
now is it gonna go for the king's Indian
who was um
or maybe the grinfelt uh the grinfelts
didn't really have an idea of what line
I was going to play here though
okay let me go for uh
the classical Bishop E3
why did I go to Knight F3
I wasn't even thinking
some people are having a lot of fun
spamming
but then again why wouldn't they
spamming is fun
oh yeah this is a line
where you can actually allow white to
take with the bishop not
yeah this is the line people have been
playing I think
this is some kind of
um
fairly forced
first draw if I remember correctly
get some mods
go to a different Channel if you want
mods
maybe you're not supposed to go H4
immediately there
I prefer Anarchy I most certainly do
I think you're supposed to in a
different line at least go Bishop T5
here
because there aren't a lot of good
squares for the the Rooks
um
should be fine no
foreign
H5 H6 which is understandable the pawn
is not
it's not great on H6 either it could be
a Target there
oh so then he wants for K5 okay that
makes sense
anyway after Rook D5 I was intending to
put the bishop on C4 so I'm not too
unhappy about that
um
what should I do now should I Castle or
key too
hmm
I'm not sure I love my position here
actually I probably should Castle
yeah my king could be pretty unsafe in
the center I think
B6 is a bit surprising to me
oh he's alarming Bishop E6 but that's
clearly not very good
Mexican H5 right here
it's all kind of hard to
figure out
this time
should be fine
okay D3
but I don't love my position
but as they say you don't always have to
love it they just have to live with it
92 Bishop Space six
yeah I don't really like this
foreign
even know why I'm playing that move
I'm getting a little bit outplayed by Mr
Duda here
yeah not before I was
really worried about
okay A3
really worried it's a bit too much I was
worried
that's a good move
preventing me from taking and then
foreign
s a good Square
so I have to go here to protect
on 93
maybe not that much worse
Knight C3 Bishop has three then
okay he trades
but now I'm not sure if he has much
okay
I don't know what he's doing here
now I trade
no I don't
now I'm pushing
I think this passage should be strong
I'm not sure though
oh H5 I have a trick
Bishop page five
but now
these pieces are pretty much still meted
I think this yeah this just wins and
then D7
no it doesn't
I missed something
boy this is a mess
okay now Bishop he was expecting D7
which would have won but I thought I'd
go here first and then he flagged
oh my god
what a mess of a game
but I was winning in the final position
let me see if I was ever like much worse
no I think I was only a bit worse
foreign
oh this is clever I should have gone H7
and then Bishop T4 because then you
cannot do this
because my phone just runs
but yeah even this just waiting